let's talk about one of the most
controversial candidates in the 2024
primary field the Democratic
presidential primary I'm talking about
Robert F Kennedy Jr now as a reminder
Bobby Kennedy Jr is the son of Robert F
Kennedy Robert F Kennedy was
assassinated while running for president
an extraordinarily gifted politician was
Robert F Kennedy Bobby Kennedy Jr is
also the nephew of former president John
F Kennedy who is of course also
assassinated while serving as president
so Bobby Kennedy comes from this
political Dynasty that has impacted
American political history for a very
long time Environmental Lawyer activist
Who has fought for clean water and
renewable energy and climate justice has
a long record of advocacy for really
important issues poverty civil rights
Health Care democracy things that he
truly inherited from his late Father
Robert Kennedy and he's a super
interesting candidate and a nice guy who
I've met I had dinner with we have many
friends in common and also
he has become a very powerful
anti-vaccine voice he says he's not
against vaccines but simply for tested
and safe vaccines but when we actually
look at the disinformation that he has
spread not only about vaccines but also
talking about hydroxychloroquine as if
it's proven to work for Cove I mean
there's a long list of concerning stuff
from Bobby Kennedy Jr he's made
concerning comments about Russia and
Ukraine taking the some sort of strange
softly pro-putin perspectives he has
talked about
um uh he's actually talked about gay
frog said I'm talking about Bobby
Kennedy Jr here not Alex Jones
um and he also I mean just like as
another example he's made wild
unsubstantiated claims about China he
recently said on Newsmax of all places
that China is developing a racist bio
weapon that targets People based on
ethnicity listen to this well what what
I worry about is is a wmd like a virus I
think gain of function something do you
worry about that because I see that as
sort of the next the next big fight
because you know those viruses don't see
any borders and uh and they're
relatively cheap to do this gain of
function I mean it's just so that's what
I worry about more than the big Hardware
yeah you're exactly right and we know
that the Chinese
are developing ethnic bio weapons bio
weapons that are designed to attack
people of certain racial types and the
and we're doing the same thing we okay
so does he provide any evidence that
that's happening he does not
is there any evidence that I was able to
find no I was able to find some
conjecture about this from last month
also without evidence but I was not able
to find any evidence that that's going
on is it possible that you could make a
racist bio weapon it might be possible
so so like an ethnic bio weapon
hypothetically which targets people of
specific ethnicities or races or
genotypes
could conceivably be created but experts
and officials say it's it's not totally
clear that you could do it uh you might
be able to genetically engineer some
pathogen to Target DNA markers that are
specific to some racial or ethnic group
maybe like maybe it could be done
another possibility would be like a gene
therapy that creates a virus to Target
particular DNA sequences but there are
many forget about the ethical challenges
let's assume the ethics go out the
window there are some insane technical
challenges to do this and one of them is
the one that often comes up in debates
about IQ there is such genetic diversity
within ethnic groups that such a
technology
would be extremely difficult to actually
do what I'm not saying it's impossible
but right now extreme hurdles and no
evidence that it's being done but Bobby
Kennedy says oh this thing is happening
another example Bobby Kennedy Jr is
hosting a so-called Health policy
Roundtable
featuring unhinged conspiracy theorists
Sherry Tenpenny Sherry ten penny is this
um uh
person I don't want to get into the
whole osteopathy thing again
she's a a an individual who happens to
be an osteopath who has
um made all sorts of insane claims about
everyone you know is soon going to be
dead from the covid vaccine and uh all
of these other things so how do we what
do we make of Bobby Kennedy Jr is he a
viable Challenger to Joe Biden should we
support or oppose him for me the the
situation is pretty clear Bobby Kennedy
Jr is articulate articulate and smart
he delivers really powerful speeches
even with the struggles of his voice
with the dysphonia he still
delivers very powerful speeches he
appeals to emotion and reason in a way
that clearly resonates with people he
has a personal story and a family Legacy
that can be inspirational to voters he's
right on many issues when you look at
health care and green New Deal
minimum wage Criminal Justice Reform
voting rights expansion ending Wars
Bobby Kennedy Jr is right on many issues
on the other side
he is dangerously unhinged in some areas
the promotion of unproven conspiracy
theories the pseudoscience this stuff
really undermines some of the core
structures that go towards public health
and National Security
um he seems disconnected with reality
quite frankly on some of those issues he
will often attack fellow Democrats who
happen to disagree with him on some of
these issues he's supported by a Super
PAC tied to Maga he seems to be gaining
support from folks on the right who see
him merely as a Chaos Agent potentially
to derail Joe Biden and put a hardcore
right winger in the Oval Office so
on the one hand there is much to like
about Bobby Kennedy Jr
in some sense I would love to support
the guy
um but based on his current positions I
don't think that that's something that I
can do I also don't think he can win the
nomination nor the general election uh
with the views that he has he may be
able to he may be able to damage Joe
Biden
um but I don't believe that he has a
path to the Democratic nomination nor am
I convinced at this point that he would
have a path to the presidency if he
somehow got on the ballot let me know
your thoughts I am not just laughing him
off I'm actually giving you a more
nuanced perspective than some are
willing to give about Bobby Kennedy Jr
but at this point it doesn't seem like
in its totality it's something that I
can support